hello everyone and welcome to a
wonderful game from the junior speed
Chess Championship final uh it is
gookish versus around aksadvani and uh
this game perfectly illustrates how not
everything about uh chess is in uh is in
the the quantity of the pieces but
really the quality of the pieces where
sometimes uh even two queens are not
enough to actually do something about
the position now this is from the three
plus one section the five plus one
section uh ended with a draw then the
three plus one section I think this is
game seven uh gookish is already leading
by two points so it would be uh very
very good for uh around the the strike
back to try and get uh you know get the
match tied uh so let's check it out it's
a beautiful game you guys will enjoy it
it just finished googlish has the white
pieces and he opens with the D4 uh we
have Knight F6 C4 uh G6 Knights the C3
and now Bishop to G7 the king's Indian
defense is on the board Ponte for D6
Knight to F3 and uh castles by
E5 so all uh very standard stuff here uh
all the top moves of the Orthodox
variation of the king's Indian defense
we have castles uh and now now here
Knight to C6 is the most common move the
Knight A6 Knight beat and as far as that
might be to D7 uh those are the moves
you want to play also he captures on D4
but H6 is a very very rare move uh has
been played a couple of times by some
very strong players for example iron
played it against Magnus Carlsen uh in
the Arjun edges he played it against
Jordan Palm Forest uh but uh you know uh
really only a handful of games in the
database with Rook to E1 Knight B to D7
and now Bishop back to F1 uh Now The
Rook also nicely covers the the four
square uh B6 preparing to feed and get
to the dark Square bishop and now there
is a game where A3 was played uh back in
uh to 2000 and back in the year 2000 it
was played by between Dimitri elizarro
and igorith from the Russian Under 12
Championship but here we have Pawn to D5
and it is now as of move 10 that we have
a completely new game it's okay how do
you treat this D5 expansion in the
center will of course by Ponte A5 this
is a key move in most of these positions
you have to cover the B4 Square you do
not want to allow white to play B4
because you like your knight and C5 and
as white already advanced D5 there will
be no way to kick your knight away from
C5 so okay Pawn to G3 white continues
development Knight to C5 this is a
beautiful piece here and the bishop to
G2 we have Knight to H7 now preparing
the center now this standard Central
breakthrough with Pawn to F5 and now
Bishop to E3 we have Pawn to F5 and E
captures on F5 we have G captures on F5
uh sort of messing up your kings the
king's position a little bit but um if
you're a king's Indian defense player
you know that this is exactly what you
need to do Knight to H4 making uh use of
that newly discovered G6 square that is
no longer defended and now Queen to F6
with King to H1 and now a pawn to 4
there are many moves you could consider
like simply developing preparing to
bring the other Rook into the game also
Knight to G5 is very nice but this also
works and now you gain more control over
D3 and F3 also 3D E5 Square so maybe you
can shift the Knight over to E5 to put
more pressure on D3 and F3 from here uh
but we have Knight the B5 first going
after the C7 pawn and now Knights the D3
and okay your Rook is hanging so
naturally good cash moves it to F1 you
could consider Knight captures and C7
first but it's Blitz three plus one you
don't want to over calculate uh and if
you're wondering what about bishop.d4 is
this doing anything for us not really
and the bishop is the only piece
guarding the F2 Pawn so if you played
this uh Queen characters on D4 is an
automatic now after you capture Knight
captures an F2 check you will uh win
back the queen and retain a better
position so here just Rook to F1 by
gokish and now Queen captures on B2
grabbing that pawn Rook to B1 and queen
captures an A2 so Booker's sacrificing a
few points for uh for uh activity Knight
captures on C7 attacking The Rook Rook
to A7 and now uh you could throw in a
bishop capture some B6 then comes Rook
to B7 uh but uh the immediate Knight the
E6 is played by gukash and now Bishop
captures an E6 with d captures and E6
and now Queen captures on C4 and if
you're wondering what uh what is Google
is doing why is he giving up all of
these pawns uh as he's done three pawns
and if those pawns start marching
forward could be very ugly for him uh he
plays Pawn to E7 uh he doesn't even want
to waste time with Bishop capture some
B6 he just attacks the rook and now he's
a inviting Rook captures on E7 because
other moves aren't really all that
spectacular if you move the Rook the
Knight captures on F5 captures a pawn
also defends on E7 so you have to
capture The Rook captures and not Knight
the G6 wins The Exchange but that's a
lot of Pawns to give up just to take an
exchange it's okay Rook e to F7 he grabs
The Rook on f8 Knight captures an f8 and
now Rook captures on B6 he he has to
start collecting those pawns otherwise
he's just gonna get crushed but around
has time now he starts advancing his a
pawn uh we have real characters on D6
Ponte A3 and even Bishop captures and H6
so quickly grabbing those three pawns uh
but now okay it would be perhaps a bit
too ambitious to play ponte2 right away
then you allow Bishop captures on G7 so
around decides to save the bishop Bishop
to E5 as it's a very useful Defender and
now he will continue pushing his Pawn we
have rooked the d8 now the Knight cannot
move uh Pawn to E2 and now comes Queen
to H5 and this is the first move where
uh Booker sort of gives up the edge uh
the problem is uh uh Queen to D2 is the
move you have to play but even if you
played the absolute strongest move that
is Queen to D2 it's a very long Force to
draw I'm just gonna show it because it's
a lot of fun uh Pawn to F4 you have to
of course stop Queen G5 now comes Rook
the A8 to prevent of course uh you have
to guard the A1 square but still just A1
Queen you will have to give up one of
the Rooks then Bishop captures an A1
Rook captures and now Pawn to E3 and you
open up at the at the white King's
possession for example phone captures
you're going to capture on G3 Bishop to
F4 and now you further trade a knight
capture spawn captures Queen captures
and F4U trade Queens even captures
captures age captures and G3 you can
attack the pawn but now King to H2 and
okay white is up upon but this is a draw
yeah you don't really care that the pawn
is defended because the ones the Knight
comes let's say to H5 you can just
capture on G3 regardless of uh whether
the Rook is guarding or not because you
can even give up the the rook and Knight
for this pawn and rook and it's still a
draw of course the the Bushman King will
not be able to Checkmate the black king
so uh the absolute top move in this
position equals only a draw
and glucose not satisfied with that he
goes for the aggressive Queen to H5 but
now he runs into a refutation of this
queen to H5 move and that is Knight
captures an F2 check now you cannot
capture because A1 comes with check so
King to G1 and now another a second
brilliant move in a row Queen to C5 now
threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries and if you're careless here
let's say you play something like a
bishop captures and a fate you attack
Black's Queen uh you run into Knight
stage three check and it's game over for
those of you who perhaps have never seen
a smothered mate uh you have to run away
there's no other mulking the H1 and not
the wonderful Queen to G1 check forces
The Rook to capture and now Knight to F2
a beautiful smother Checkmate so uh you
have to be be careful of such things so
Lucas makes room for his King he plays
H4 he does not want to be smothered and
now Knight the G4 check with King to H1
and now uh it's it's a very tricky
position where you have to play A1 Queen
first uh the problem the point is that
after A1 Queen uh Queen to G6 for
example with check Bishop to G7 and now
only now you play real captures on A1 as
the bishop cannot move so Knight
captures on H6 will be played and black
is perfectly fine there is nothing to
worry about here uh black is even quite
better however uh here Knight captures
and H6 was played right away by raunak
and now Queen captures on H6 A1 Queen
but now it's a little bit different
because Queen to G5 check Rook to G7 and
now Queen captures an F5 and now you
have a bit of an issue here the the the
Knight here is being threatened and also
you you have to decide whether Queen
captures on F1 check is something you
want to do okay it's it will lead to a
draw but roundock also wants to now
Fight For the Win he is up a full Queen
so Queen to A3 now he guards the f8
square sufficiently and now we have
Queen to E6 with check you could also
Play Bishop captures on e4 but it only
yields a draw so Queen to E6 with check
and now what would you play here in this
position it's a very very a very
interesting uh one uh where the move you
you all want to play is not the correct
move you all want to play King the h8
which is what was played in the game uh
King to H7 is something that we would
all avoid with few seconds on the clock
because it just runs into Bishop
captures an E4 check but Bishop captures
an E4 check is the exact thing you you
have to allow because okay you will
suffer through one check but it also
frees up this diagonal for you to start
checking the white king and there's
nothing better here after Bishop
captures an E4 let's say King to each
eight now you try Queen to H6 with check
King to G8 and now Bishop to F5 for
example going for Bishop to E6 but it's
too late now comes Queen the A8 with
check and it's it's just a draw Rook
capture 78 now I play Queen Queen to D5
with check
um uh King has to move and now of course
you will pick up the Rook But First
bishop captures and G3 with check King
H3 Queen capture 78 and now after Bishop
D6 check it will just be a draw Knight
captures Queen captures and we will have
a draw by repetition Queen H6 King to
Jade Queen D6 checking th8 and queen to
H6 and so on however after Queen D6
check uh of course Rana played what
everyone would play dude won't allow
Bishop captures uh on e4 with check but
chess is often counter-intuitive like
that and now the difference is Queen to
H6 would check uh now uh you don't have
a move here if you play Rook to H7 then
of course Rook captures an f8 just ends
the game you have to start giving up
queens and once you give up all of your
Queens it will be uh it will end with
Queen captures and f8 Checkmate so of
course King to G8 was played which was
perfectly fine in the other line that
we've just shown uh but now comes Bishop
to H3
and Bishop to H3 is the real star move
of the position uh and now Bishop to E6
is Unstoppable there is no no avoiding
this uh and of course the this diagonal
isn't open so you do not have Queen to
A8 so Queen captures and G3 was played
now you are threatening Checkmate here
but it doesn't matter Bishop to E6 check
we have Rook to F7 only move for black
and now bookish finishes it off um uh
strongly with Bishop captures on F7 and
this of course is now Checkmate so there
we have it uh in a bad position he even
suffered uh you know a position through
uh two brilliant moves by by raunak but
it wasn't enough gookish it was as
slippery as a fish and there was um you
know as hard as around I've tried he
just couldn't get the job done and then
he gave him one chance that uh move that
pretty much every player uh you know in
existence would move the king to each no
no one moves the king to H7 here with
few seconds on the clock you know it
just doesn't work that way uh I don't
know I could be wrong but I don't know
can't get you like uh aside from maybe
Magnus uh you do not play King to H7
here uh so yeah that's the game I really
hope you guys enjoyed it uh just
finished so you know fresh out of the
oven uh I would like to thank Andre
luxnikov bulletchestriller.com I've
actually checked the bullet just
thriller.com if you guys want to check
it out it's a movie that is now coming
out about an underground tournament uh
you know where they invite chess players
to battle it out and uh they don't say
actually what happens when they lose but
I as I understand from the trailer it's
not very nice uh so there we have a
thank you for that the Pancho Vermont
Brian Baker and Dan McCormick for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos
Sarah thank you for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check up on
you wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the Chess World uh there
you have it sometimes even two queens
are not enough uh thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent
resume day